yes we will definitely go to telcon soon
look who's fancy oh am i wearing an
ascot i didn't notice
big night at the snakehole lounge it's a
launch party for dennis feinstein's new
fragrance
allergic for men pawnee's own dennis
feinstein is a real up-and-comer in the
world of microbead perfumes and body
sprays his ether based perfume
blackout was named one of maxim's top
hundred ways
to trick someone into sex club opens at
six event starts at nine
welcome to e720s end of the world
celebration the entire party's a vip
area there's also a double viper
a triple vip area and the centurion club
elite vip area sponsored by sobe
lifewater
no one's a lot in there not even us we
also hired
10 huge scary bouncers with earpieces
what up keith
he actually once tossed me out of a club
three years ago water under the bridge
dj bluntz is mixing up some new beats
ballers and ballarats
fasten your seat belts the perfect party
begins link
now
oh thank god no one shows up to a good
party on time
if anyone had actually showed up right
now the whole party would have been
ruined it would have been a disaster i
don't want a lap party
forever young i wanna be
um what's up do you want to
go to lunch uh no i don't really feel
like going to jj's we can go anywhere
your choice i'm i'm buying can i get
apps and deserts
desserts are what i call desserts tray
trays or entrees i call
sandwiches sammies sandusels or adam
sandlers
air conditioners are cool blasters with
a z i don't know where that came from
i call cakes big old cookies i call
noodles
long ass rice fried chicken is fry fried
chicken chick
chicken parm is chicken chicken parm
brown chicken cacciatore
chicken catch i call eggs pre-birds or
future birds
root beer is super water tortillas are
bean blankies
and i call forks food rakes
akash buddy of course i came to you
first you're the best carpet man in
pawnee
but here's my question do your carpets
match your drapes
[Laughter]
how do you make any event classy on a
budget red carpet
my entire apartment is red carpet on top
of that
leading into my bedroom a second red
carpet oh what's this in my shoe
red carpet insole everywhere i go i'm
walking
on red carpet five minutes what up
playboy
you like that jacket it's a pretty dope
cut right yeah can i have it mom
i could wear it to homecoming 300 bucks
for something you're just gonna grow out
of in a month
forget it wait i can rent it to you
really yeah it's part of a business i
run
high-end clothes rentals for teens
tweens and everything in betweens
that jacket is 20 bucks a week
done this is a great idea he grows so
fast i never want to buy him anything
nice
what's the name of your business rent a
swag
starting now when life gives me lemons
i'm gonna slice them up into wedges
and throw them into vodka tonics which i
will then sip
in a burlesque nightclub that i co-own
with actor tay diggs
and two of the pussycat dolls
dj butts is in the building here to
announce that tom
having fun is in the building
[Music]
donatella t-mobile three words for you
treat yo self treat yourself 2011
once a year donna and i spend a day
treating ourselves what do we treat
ourselves to
clothes treat yourself fragrances treat
yourself massage it treat yourself
mimosas treat yourself fine leather
goods
treat yourself it's the best day of the
year the best day of the year
set list no need so what you're just
gonna put your ipod on shuffle
no but i could you wanna know why
because every single song you own is a
banger
every song i download has to pass a
series of rigorous tests
to answer one simple question is it a
banger
how many beats per minute how many drops
how dope are the drops
were any acoustic instruments used if so
it is not a banger
i once accidentally downloaded the
lumineer song
i had to throw away my whole computer
just to be safe hey
look who it is hey hey tom jean ralphio
professional basketball players what's
up jello shot
can i ask you guys a question how
exactly are you making money you want to
know how we make money do you want to
know how we make money
by literally printing our own money we
bought a printing
press this prints builds with our faces
and the e720 logo on them we promote the
company
by going to clubs and tossing the bills
in the air and screaming free money
okay you can't just print your own money
uh
this past you stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah what's the deal baby one second hit
the party switch the next second you're
on business
i need to see all of your books you got
a baby baby
get in the books oh snapple are we
calling everybody baby now
because honestly i love that are we
saying snapple anytime we think
something's dope cause i love
that baby you know what i love
[Applause]
[Music]
i hate to say this but sometimes
you gotta work a little so you can ball
a lot that was beautiful
that changed me i'll give you ten
minutes
i didn't eat those stupid mini calzones
have a food rule
number six never eat anything with the
sauce i have to dip myself
drizzle it on for me i'm not your maid
i've never taken the high road
but i tell other people too cause then
there's more room for me on the low road
cash money i'm gonna make it rain
i just gotta pick that up real quick
gentlemen
swan song how you living yes
why aren't you in snake juice i'm more
of a whiskey man
come on ron come here come here for a
bit you're good right there listen you
got to jump on the tommy town express
this guy has some of the best investment
ideas i've ever heard in my life
make a baby tuxedo clothing line a
department store with a guest list
white fur earmuffs for men contact
lenses
that display text messages and then a
phone that smells good
own a nightclub called eclipse that's
only open
for one hour two times a year cover
charge
five thousand dollars i can keep going
how about this ron try snake juice if
you like it you gotta talk it up
all night if you don't i'll shave john
ralphio's head
yeah i'd like to see that hit me
a lot riding on this
[Music]
damn if that isn't delicious why am i
gonna love it
skye maul come check out my tent
i ordered a bunch of crap off skymall i
got my tv
my xbox dvd awesome bed right there
dj roomba's in the mix uh it's like i'm
not even camping
this is actually a dog couch but it's
super comfortable
i'm like an elephant okay if i walk into
a room
it's like okay he's in there love love
fades away
but things things are forever
[Music]
tommy timberlake you look like
encyclopedia brown
sequins try without the gloves
sequence minus the gloves hey what's up
i'm tom is my shirt lighting up cause i
didn't even notice
all right guys let's talk accessories be
honest which can do you like better
dragon
serpent dragon serpent bell buckle says
what's cracking i can have it say
whatever i want i can say what's
cracking up tom
what's cracking girl what's cracking
boob eagle medallion
go go well as far as white leather suits
go
horrible i like it
i want to open up my own club one day
maybe call it something like club a dub
dub
or the club marine sort of a submarine
themed club
or tom's bistro the word bistro is
classy
it's not often that i see someone with
your sparkle and passion
that's what makes businesses work
passion
so mr haverford let's get to it
what idea are you passionate about
i've got two words for you
tom's bistro an old-fashioned old world
italian restaurant classy authentic
ambiance
in a small town setting why does that
say dry cleaning chemical transactional
holding company
ben you brought the wrong easel god
can't take this guy anywhere
let me paint you a picture tom's bishop
will have all the classic elements
but with modern twists an oak bar live
music
and sunday brunch with scrambled eggs so
fluffy they'll be like little pillows
for your bacon
throw my swag on took a look in the
mirror said what's up
dylan are you sure you don't want me to
drive i'm good to drive
you wanna come and play video games pull
over man
that place has good chicken i'm hungry
you